[Música]
qué pensaría si dijera que estamos
viviendo la mayor crisis de la historia
de la humanidad y todavía hemos empezado
a hacerle frente
y si os dijera además que no sólo hemos
creado nuestro propio enemigo sino que
nos hemos acostumbrado a convivir con él
y ya no somos capaces de percibir lo
fijado en esta imagen
quizá alguno como mucho el hecho que la
fecha o puede que ni siquiera eso diga
qué bueno que ya sabía que el
coronavirus llegó al mundo antes de lo
que se dice por desgracia prácticamente
a nadie oa casi nadie le choca la
terrible contaminación que se aprecia en
la imagen y es que para esto en china
hace ya años que utilizan mascarilla
para protegerse el mayor desafío al que
debe enfrentarse la humanidad es a
frenar el calentamiento global
el coronavirus que llegó el año pasado y
paró de inmediato el mundo mató en 2020
a 2 millones de personas
por suerte gracia un esfuerzo titánico
de toda la población mundial unido
algo tan pequeño como esto una vacuna
vamos a poder salvarnos
el calentamiento global lleva con
nosotros más de dos décadas y mata cada
año según la onu a 7 millones de
personas por desgracia el ataque está
siendo tan progresivo que sin darnos
cuenta estamos viviendo la cuenta atrás
para el desastre mirad el consenso
científico a nivel mundial nos dice que
si nos disminuimos las emisiones
contaminantes prácticamente ya el mundo
para el 2030 habrá cambiado y no habrá
marcha atrás para solucionarlo tenemos
la responsabilidad como especie de
encontrar una vacuna a tiempo contra
esta crisis climática
llega a las renovables por favor que
levante la mano quien piensa que la
energía renovable nos pueden ayudar en
esto
efectivamente prácticamente toda la sala
gracias la energía renovable y esperanza
la energía eólica solar e hidráulica no
tienen competencia y son claves para
frenar esta crisis
pero claro qué ocurre cuando no sopla el
viento no tenemos sol o no podemos mover
el agua de lluvia
pues que por desgracia casi siempre
terminamos quemando combustibles fósiles
gas natural petróleo carbón que producen
esas emisiones contaminantes que
favorecen el calentamiento global y van
transformando poco a poco nuestro mundo
en un infierno la energías renovables
necesitan de un aliado de una energía
limpia que les ayude cada vez que están
no están disponibles y la necesitan de
manera urgente
y ahora llega la nuclear ya estoy viendo
cómo van cambiando las caras
seguramente será pidiera que levantaran
la mano a la gente que apoya esta
energía
quizá la mitad de la sala no levantaría
la levantaría más tímidamente existen
muchos miedos mis de creencias sobre la
energía nuclear de hecho cuando alguien
le habla de energía nuclear rápidamente
le viene a la cabeza una bomba atómica
no le viene a la cabeza otros usos como
por ejemplo la medicina nuclear que
tanta vida ha salvado no obstante una
central nuclear no es ni nunca podría
ser una cosa u otra es únicamente es una
central que produce energía eléctrica
por cierto el humo que aparece siempre
las imágenes de las centrales nucleares
no es más que vapor de agua es algo
totalmente inocuo para el medio ambiente
es una energía limpia otra cosa
totalmente diferente son los accidentes
nucleares como la catástrofe
injustificable de chernóbil o las
consecuencias del accidente de fukushima
por tanto para apoyar a las renovables
la energía nuclear no solo debe de ser
limpia sino que debe ser también una
energía segura
son segura la central nuclear
vamos a hacer una comprobación visual
fijaos
vamos a ver para cada tipo de energía
cuántas muertes producen cada muerte va
estar representada por un granito de
arroz pues bien si utilizaran únicamente
energía nuclear para producir una gran
cantidad de energía mil trabajo ahora el
consumo eléctrico en españa por cuatro
años según datos de cambridge house si
podrían llegar a producir hasta 90
muertes para este cálculo se han
utilizado la muerte directa o indirecta
de accidentes nucleares así como muertes
de la minería del uranio en el
combustible nuclear para la misma
cantidad energía si sólo utilizará la
energía eólica se producirían 150
muertes y 400 muertes si sólo se
utilizará energía solar para la misma
cantidad de energía principalmente
derivado de accidentes laborales en la
construcción de las instalaciones
1400 muertes si solo utilizamos energía
hidráulica fijaron un solo accidente el
accidente de bankia o domenchina produjo
más muertes que todos los accidentes
nucleares juntos además de devastar
miles de hectáreas de terreno un solo
accidente en energía hidráulica al final
la seguridad de la energía nuclear se
parece mucho a la seguridad de un avión
hay mucha gente que teme viajar en avión
no obstante los datos nos dicen que es
mucho más probable sufrir un accidente
mortal en el traslado en coche al
aeropuerto que durante el propio vuelo
hay muy pocos accidentes aéreos eso lo
convierte en el medio de transporte más
seguro que hay pues a la energía nuclear
le pasa algo parecido no obstante los
mayores asesinos sin duda son los
combustibles fósiles para la misma
cantidad de energía si solo quemamos gas
natural se producirían 4.000 muertes
si utilizáramos petróleo 30.000 muertes
y cuánto ocurriría si utilizáramos solo
carbón
pues si utilizáramos carbón
cien mil muertes y no sólo eso sino que
el 80 por ciento de la energía que se
consume en el mundo proviene de la quema
de combustibles fósiles
hasta que no seamos capaces de aceptar
la barbaridad que le estamos haciendo al
mundo no seremos capaces de afrontar la
crisis y la que estamos viviendo
bien la energía nuclear no solo debe ser
limpia y segura sino que además tiene
que ser sostenible
esto significa que genere poco residuo
alguno de vosotros ha pensado qué
cantidad de residuos genera por el
simple hecho consumir electricidad
tejado si solamente utilizáramos gas
natural para producir la energía que
consume un hogar medn españa durante un
año
necesitaríamos media piscina olímpica de
gas natural solo para nosotros
si utilizáramos petróleo la misma
cantidad de combustible que el
combustible que le echaré a tu coche
para ir desde aquí granada a moscú y
volver dos veces
y si utilizáramos carbón la misma
cantidad de carbón que el carbón vegetal
que necesitaríamos por una barbacoa de
2000 personas
sabe en cambio qué cantidad de
combustible nuclear se necesitaría
esto
esta sería la cantidad de combustible
nuclear que necesitaremos para la misma
cantidad de energía que además cuando ya
no puede reciclarse más si se considera
un residuo se almacena de manera segura
y permanente bajo tierra como un almacén
con nuestro que está construyendo ahora
con finlandia uno de los países con
mayor conciencia ecológica del mundo que
apoya el uso de la energía nuclear
en mi opinión está precisamente en la
vacuna que necesitamos para salir de
esta crisis global
bien y no solo tiene que ser sostenible
la energía nuclear también tiene que ser
social es decir que abarate el precio de
la factura de la luz os voy a contar
como lo hacen cada barrita representa la
cantidad de potencia instalada
disponible de cada tipo de energía en
españa como veis tenemos bastante
energía solar mucha más energía eólica
instalada tenemos bastante energía
hidráulica muy poquita nuclear y
efectivamente tenemos centrales
contaminantes instaladas en españa no
obstante tal como funciona nuestro
sistema es que si encendemos la luz
necesitamos energía primero arrancar ya
las centrales limpias y sólo en los
momentos determinados arrancarían estas
centrales que queman combustibles
fósiles la teoría está muy bien verdad
pensad
qué estabas haciendo el 7 de enero de
ya sé que hace mucho pero yo lo sé que
estaba viendo
por lo voy a decir estabais pagando uno
de los precios de la factura de la luz
más caro de la historia de españa' que
ocurre exactamente pues en pleno
temporal filomena en momentos críticos
como la una de la tarde
menos del 4% de los paneles solares
pudieron funcionar sólo uno de cada diez
molinos de viento aerogeneradores de
estos que veis por las carreteras pudo
funcionar y menos de la mitad de la
energía hidráulica pudo funcionar esto
es lo que se llama energía intermitente
y es el gran talón de aquiles de la
energía renovable que por mucha
instalada que tenga un país no siempre
está cuando se le necesita y esto por
desgracia ocurre muchas veces al año
la energía nuclear aunque tengamos muy
poquito funcionó prácticamente al máximo
pero no fue suficiente y una de cada
tres centrales contaminantes estuvo
funcionando no sólo produciendo eso casa
es nocivo a la atmósfera sino también
elevando el precio la factura de la luz
hacia el infinito porque los
combustibles fósiles además de ser
contaminantes pueden llegar a ser muy
caro
un país cuanta más energía nuclear tenga
más difícil será que se le dé estas
situaciones 'francia sin ir más lejos un
país que apoya firmemente la energía
nuclear posee un precio de la factura de
la luz hasta un 40% más barata que la
nuestra
al final la situación es muy clara para
apoyar a las energías renovables cada
vez que no estén disponibles sólo
tenemos dos opciones o la apoyamos con
energía nuclear o la apoyamos con
combustibles fósiles
y el problema es que todos nosotros sin
darnos cuenta estamos eligiendo la
segunda opción
casi de manera oculta se realiza así
fijaron tres que exagero
estos son ejemplos de como país se
aprovechando el miedo o cierran
centrales nucleares pero si contar que
las consecuencias directas en la quema
de combustibles fósiles porque bueno si
aumenta el precio de la luz si al final
pagamos lo de siempre y sobre los
compromisos climáticos pues si otros
países están haciéndolo tan mal como
nosotros y entre unos y otros estamos
acabando con el planeta
y no crees que en españa estamos mucho
mejor este el plan de energía y clima ha
aprobado en nuestro país y que se está
instaurando de manera progresiva dice
sin carbón lo cual está bien y con muy
poquita nuclear
pero claro
con que apoyamos la energías renovables
cuando éstas no están disponibles pues
ante esta pregunta
nadie quiere responderlo nadie quiere
responderlo porque se sabe que al final
el igual que otros países terminaremos
incumpliendo nuestro propio plan y
arrancando centrales contaminantes
quemando combustibles fósiles cavando
entre todos nosotros nuestra propia
tumba
la conclusión de todo esto es que bueno
si queremos salvar el planeta estamos
remando precisamente en la dirección
opuesta
bill gates famoso no solo por inventar
windows sino por vaticinar en una charla
tdt en 2015 en que llegaría una pandemia
mundial a la que no estaríamos
preparados decía en su última entrevista
que estaba empezando a perder la
esperanza de que la humanidad asumiera
que necesita la energía nuclear para
salir de esta crisis ahora más que nunca
debemos de confiar en la amistad entre
energía nuclear y energía renovable el
mundo lleva más de 20 años diciéndonos
sálvame si no lo hacemos bueno la vida
continuará seguiremos quemando
combustibles fósiles aunque nos
tendremos que acostumbrar a usar
mascarilla de manera permanente oa
realizar confinamiento para evitar
muertes por contaminación atmosférica o
lo que es mucho peor a ser refugiados
del calentamiento global y abandonar
ciudades enteras convertido en un
completo desierto cuando nos pregunten
nuestro hijo le diremos que bueno es que
en 2021 por no había ninguna solución
factible
la solución existe si queremos salvar el
planeta y superar esta crisis solo
tenemos que superar nuestro miedo muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]